je filme sur la caméra selphy au bord de
la mer je suis posé un regard des
petites cabanes en plastique
on n'est pas mal pour vous parler
justement de la caméra du honorio 20
[Musique]
au loin derrière là bas on va tenter un
zoom on a new york vous une fois 5 zoom
x vous x 10 soit là alors ça c'est très
très très pixélisé mais c'est new york
tout au bout on revient en mode un peu
normal voilà
je vous explique le problème là on est
au départ à l'aéroport de newmarke noir
qu noir mari à new york paris montréal
montréal quarto cataraqui dominicaine
sauf qu'il ya eu un souci on n'a pas pu
prendre la correspondance du coup on a
fait montréal new york l'ont fait new
york par groupe l'état a passé une nuit
sur place
voyage très long mais franchement ça
vaut le coup vous savez de loire new
york un peu de l'autre côté là bas donc
en même temps on fait les honneurs view
va là on est sur les caméras de celle-ci
vous et montrez new york soit la caméra
arrière pensée plein de choses à mettre
super
à
aujourd'hui on teste est la caméra du
honneur view 20 caméras avant caméra
arrière tout va y passer
photos de jour photos de nuit on va tout
voir et là je vous emmène en république
dominicaine dans un spot us magnifique
tout ce qui va être filmée aujourd'hui
bal est fait uniquement avec le nord du
vin comme ça pourquoi vraiment vous
rendre compte de tout on commence
forcément on ne suit pas la caméra
arrière comme ça vous voyez je vous
laisse admirer le panorama
[Musique]
maintenant c'est un tour du côté de la
caméra selphy la toute petite caméra qui
est poinçonnet dans l'écran pour cacher
ici en bas alors on va aussi tester les
photos on va tester le mode portrait et
au final on va voir si ça intéressant
oui la montre moi en fait quoi alors
c'est pas le principe ont fait le trou
là
qui prend quoi toi sois tu prends la
pelle moi je prends quoi moi je croisais
avec ça ouais et j'enlève hockey et le
but c'est quoi c'est faire un grand trou
ici c'est ça ok bon enfin un grand trou
ici on voit la lionne j'espère que ça va
bien comme ça
et bien c'est quoi sa boisson point
yacht c'est toi que tu manges la
s'écouler et bennane au plan des
plantains et toi c'est quoi et tout ça
avec la vue mer derrière on est au top
[Applaudissements]
là je filme sur la caméra selphy au bord
de la mer je suis posé un regard des
petites cabanes en plastique
on n'est pas mal pour vous parler
justement de la caméra du aux normes ue
20 alors je ne sais pas du tout ainsi le
fonds va être génial pas génial top pas
du tout le truc qui est cool c'est que
c'est la toute première caméra sur le
quai le voir comme un capteur arrière
fait le sony à 1586 ça c'est une
première gros capteur de 48 méga pixels
alors vous le voyez lorsque après des
visites et là on est dans des conditions
qui sont juste optimale ça marche
franchement super bien c'est hyper
agréable pour les fauteuils beaucoup de
lumière c'est génial pour la vidéo ça
fonctionne plutôt pas mal mais c'est
vrai qu'il faut qu'il ait vraiment fait
une côté de la photo
la caméra de celle filles nagent pas mal
mais c'est pas son point fort à l'avant
on a une 25 méga pixels bon elle ira
pour dc le fil offre là des collections
de luminosité optimale ça ira très bien
mais le gros gros gros focus qui est
fait c'est vraiment sur la caméra
arrière avec l'ouverture de f 1.8 qui
fonctionne bien en conditions de bonne
luminosité et en conditions de faible
luminosité
mais saviez vous le montrer juste après
c'est que au nord a fait le choix
contrairement
glisse d'avoir une seule caméra à
l'arrière et après de laisser faire à
une intelligence artificielle avec le
kirin 980 avec gti turbo 2.0
et franchement ça marche plutôt bien il
ya de l'intelligence artificielle et
reconnaissance des scènes sont vraiment
top
ici j'ai vue photographiées le panorama
ça ne le reconnaît plus rassuré
nourriture ça ne la reconnaît ça c'est
un truc qui est prouvé ça marche
toujours très bien et c'est un point est
aussi super cup
on a vous voulez à l'arrière une caméra
48 mégapixels absolument incroyable de
chez sonic est sûr maîtriser
on a derrière pro côté software qui est
vraiment méprisés on a de la puissance
on a une optimisation software on a
vraiment une machine qui est top toutes
les photos surtout des photos mais aussi
les vidéos dans des conditions de
luminosité comme aujourd'hui
vous serez absolument pas déçu au niveau
de l'intelligence artificielle il ya
aussi un travail qui a été fait avec
l'un des 70 sièges du frac la ripaille
et why ultra clarify l'idée en fait vous
la connaissez déjà on l'a dans google
smartphone moment faire une photo ça va
prendre plein de photos et différentes
expositions du très clair aux tréfonds
ses saveurs mills a semblé tout ça pour
vous sortir le meilleur cliché ça marche
toujours
cool c'est que vous perdez pas de
détails avec ce gros gros capteur c'est
franchement cool vous allez pouvoir vous
met dans l'image
chopper du point de détail à savoir la
caméra vous avez un zoom fin de
l'analogique et un zoom x 2 10 numérique
la qualiter que vous passez le 12.2
franchement c'est pas terrible et ça se
détériore assez rapidement alors sur
cette caméra c'est pas un deuxième
appareil photo qu'on a c'est là le
capteur 3d t'offre ta mok live qui
permet de mesurer les objets en trois
dimensions que les médias comme kinect
ça vous servira notamment cours du jeu
lorsque vous voulez vous amuser un peu
je prends la flotte sur moi c'est très
sympa ça fait du bien ça rafraîchit et
il faut imaginer aux skinheads qui voit
vraiment mesuré en trois dimensions donc
lorsque vous allez jouer à deux jeux
faire des mouvements savoir le savoir
mais ça permettra d'aller plus loin
notamment par exemple vous avez un de
neuf dans la main va pouvoir mesurer le
volume de notes et partant de là pour
voir un petit peu et styles et les
calories que vous allez pourra manger on
peut avoir plein quel usage aujourd'hui
en essayant en charge mon téléphone et
j'ai pas trouvé comment ça marche et
est-ce qu'il va y avoir une amélioration
et sont d'ailleurs mises à jour
logicielles
est ce que c'est moi qui m'a le chercher
bon c'est pas non plus le sujet du jour
on en reparlera probablement un
prochainement de ça pour l'instant on
reste vraiment focus sur la photo et la
reconnaissance des visages ça ça marche
aussi super bien c'est franchement cool
là ce que je propose c'est de faire
défiler quelques photos j'étais plein de
clichés vous allez voir super cool
vous me direz ce que vous en pensez
[Musique]
et un point qui est hyper intéressant
c'est le mode portrait il marche super
bien alors il ya une vraie maîtrise là
dessus de toute façon sur le keirin 980
ça marche parfaitement bien et en plus
c'est que j'ai pu turbo ça marche
vachement bien c'est maîtrisé ça c'est
franchement hyper cool maintenant ce que
je vous propose c'est qu'on ait faire un
tour en extérieur l'ail et c'est la nuit
on va les manger un bout on va se faire
quelques clichés ne lui auraient filmé
la nuit vous allez voir ce que ça donne
du point de vue chez nocture c'est aussi
franchement on y va il ya tout là il est
quelque chose comme 21h35 si la nuit
noire
côté photo nuit c'est franchement pas
mal
[Musique]
parce que si vous avez la technologie 4
pixels en gros vous avez un grave en
suisse elle s'avoue prendre 4 pixels
pour faire un seul pixel pour sortir des
photos en 12 mégapixels mais vraiment
super bien optimisé il ya un mode de
photos de nuit qui va prendre des photos
avec une expo hyper fond c'est une expo
plus clair ça vous assemble sabu sort
une super photo et ça vous optimiste du
tout alors nous annonce que vous pouvez
prendre vos photos directement à la main
sans que le smartphone être sur un pied
et que vous avez une stabilisation
logiciel c'est vrai est pas vrai et
c'est vrai parce que ça marche bien il
faut pas du tout bougé si vous bougez un
peu l'image quand même un peu flou c'est
pas terrible
bon ça c'est du point de détail faut
vraiment pas bougé avoue qu'elle est si
vous pouvez poser le smartphone c'est
encore mieux c'est pas aussi bon que les
mets vins trop mais franchement il fait
d'excellentes photos de nuit le détail
est vraiment bien
après pour la vidéo c'est moi ça
forcément vous avez capté beaucoup moins
de lumière donc le rendu sera beaucoup
moins terrible
[Musique]
à
voilà tout ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui au niveau de cet appareil
photo une seule grosse caméra énorme
optimisé aussi bien pour la photo du
jour que pour la photo de nuit pour la
vidéo ça marche ça veut dire un peu trop
fait l'image pour apporter de la
stabilisation logiciel mais ça
fonctionne on n'a pas encore un
vidéophone on a un excellent photophone
on se rapproche pas premièrement du
défunt au de huawei honor cette gamme de
prix on est sur un excellent photophone
et de ce point de vue là franchement je
peux que vous recommander pas ce que
vous en pensez vous en bas en
commentaire est ce que ce smartphone
peut vous intéresser à ce que la partie
photo vidéo vous tente
est ce que vous êtes satisfait alors ici
je demande vraiment des choses dans des
conditions qui sont ultra ultra optimisé
on est début février on est à la plage
il fait beau il fait chaud on est en
république dominicaine
il ya beaucoup de soleil beaucoup
lumière c'est franchement hyper agréable
dites moi tout ce que vous en pensez en
bas en commentaire bien évidemment ce
smartphone pour être emmené en reparler
ultérieurement dites moi si vous voulez
des tests spécifiques des trois cités
des choses particulières de sujets
habitat tous marqué en bas en
commentaire d'ici là je vous embrasse le
message prenez soin de vous que vous
remet un petit coup de mer histoire de
faire du bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
com